oi bom dia pessoal tudo bem a todos
quando me convidaram para falar nesse
evento eu confesso para vocês que eu
fiquei alguns minutos pensando em falar
algo que impactar a sua vida de vocês e
num primeiro momento eu me frustrei um
pouco porque eu pensei bom eu acho que
eu fiz coisas comuns a minha vida eu
nasci numa família que não tinha boas
condições financeiras estudei porque eu
acreditava que estudar era a única
oportunidade que eu tinha de mudar minha
idade e fui olhando aos poucos o fruto
desses estudos então eu fiz minha
especialização em energia renovável na
espanha que foi fruto de uma bolsa que
eu conquistei e no final dessa
retrospectiva eu pensei não mas de
verdade eventos extraordinários na vida
são coisas que eu fiz comuns mas com
dedicação com verdade e com sentido
acreditando no sentido daquilo então o
evento extraordinário que eu tenho para
contar da minha vida para vocês é que
sim nossas coisas comuns são extra
é mas você tem que acreditar naquilo que
vocês fazem vocês tem que enxergar um
sentido naquilo então assim por mais que
a gente pensa que nossa vida é uma vida
talvez comum na verdade não amanhã por
exemplo pode ser vocês aqui no meu lugar
falando para um público desse tamanho e
no meu lugar o que você estariam
pensando eu tenho dois desafios pessoais
aqui nesse evento primeiro eu falar em
público e o outro desafio pessoal é
falar em público sem que você perceba
que eu sou mineira então eu acho que o
segundo desafio pessoal é mais difícil
que o primeiro mas é que eu não vim
falar dos meus desafios pessoais hoje
para vocês aí eu vim falar de um desafio
um duplo desafio que a gente enfrenta
como sociedade que é a necessidade de
gerar mais energia para para fomentar o
desenvolvimento eo crescimento econômico
versus a necessidade de promover uma
transição para uma sociedade com menos
carbono
e quando iniciou o assunto de talvez uma
mudança climática um aumento da
temperatura do planeta alguns anos atrás
era totalmente improvável a gente
acreditar que se podia sim é gerar
energia sem nos basear nos combustíveis
fósseis hoje de fato o aquecimento
global é um consenso entre os cientistas
as consequências a gente vê no nosso dia
a dia esses clima instável verão fora de
época invernos quentes e algumas delas
já são totalmente reversíveis ou seja se
hoje a gente parasse de emitir carbono
ainda assim teríamos consequências disso
então nesse sentido o que a gente
precisa hoje sabe-se que a juíza
carbonização ele não único caminho não
tem só um caminho para descarbonização
da sociedade ela é uma série de
abordagens combinadas que devem ser
rápidas e generalizadas quando eu falo
numa abordagem
a risada primeiro eu tenho que focar na
conscientização humana institucional
seria o conscientização humana uma
concentração de nós como sociedade e
como nós nos organizamos e uma
constituição uma conscientização
institucional seria como os governos se
organizam políticas e estratégias para
se alcançar um determinado objetivo
quando eu falo numa abordagem rápida o
que que você quer dizer com isso vanessa
aí sim entra o papel das energias
renováveis como uma ferramenta essencial
de ação por isso o objetivo da onu 13
que fala sobre o combate contra a
mudança do clima engloba o objetivo da
onu da agenda 2030 que justamente vem
destacar a necessidade de aumentar a
participação das energias renováveis na
matriz elétrica mundial matriz
energética aqui eu vou introduzir um
conceito para vocês que muita gente
confunde matriz energética com mato
o que é que seria matriz energética são
aquelas fontes disponíveis na natureza
que ainda não passaram por um processo
de transformação já matriz elétrica são
aquelas fontes disponíveis apenas para a
geração de energia elétrica as duas
matrizes elas podem ser divididas em
energias renováveis e não renováveis as
energias não renováveis são aquelas
finitas ou que a sua reposição não vai
acontecer numa escala de tempo humana
então nesse sentido eu poderia estar
aqui falando as inúmeras vantagens das
energias renováveis não só para emissão
de para diminuição da emissão de carbono
mas exemplos as energias renováveis
geralmente são endógenas ou seja aquele
recurso tá naquele local então isso
diminui a dependência energética de um
país
e facilita a universalização da energia
que também é um dos objetivos um dos
objetivos sete da onu elas fomentam o
crescimento econômico a indústria local
a geração de empregos mas hoje eu queria
mostrar para vocês um pouco do do
contexto brasileiro aqui no brasil
quando a gente fala de energias
renováveis nós temos uma atriz elétrika
perdoar humilhantemente renovável porque
graças às nossas características
naturais hoje a nossa matriz elétrica
cerca de 80 ponto 4 por cento tem a
participação de renováveis graças a
nossas hidrelétricas porém para um país
é extremamente perigoso dependesse só de
uma fonte de energia mesmo que essa
energia seja renovável comer nosso caso
então hoje o governo já tá com medidas e
ações para fomentar a inserção de outras
renováveis na nossa matriz com maior
clica e a solar fotovoltaica a questão
energia já muito maduras
bom e muito competitivas mas eu queria
deixar um questionamento hoje aqui para
vocês vocês de fato acreditam que o
brasil é um país sustentável porque
cerca de oitenta por cento da nossa
matriz elétrica é predominantemente
renovável não há resposta é não porque
porque para existir geração tem que ter
uma demanda e quando eu falo em demanda
eu falo em consumo onde eu falei consumo
eu falo consumo consciente
o que significa eficiência energética
pouco se tem discutido de eficiência
energética vou fazer outra pergunta que
parece um pouco óbvia a resposta mas não
é você sabem qual a energia 100% limpa
renovável e óleo com a hidrelétrica não
a única energia 100% limpa primeiro é
aquela que não precisa ser gerada e
segundo é aquela que economizar da todas
as fontes de energias renováveis geram
impacto no ciclo de vida hidrelétricas
por suas imensas áreas alagadas solar
fotovoltaica pelos minerais que compõem
as placas enfim todas elas vão gerar um
certo impacto então a reflexão que eu
queria deixar hoje para vocês é que a
gente tem que olhar para os dois lados
da equação não só para geração será que
esse tema não é discutido por que não
interessa alguns setores economicamente
fim de otimizar demandas melhorar
sistemas diminuir perdas por que de fato
a geração quando eu falo de renováveis
elas já são competitivas ela já geram
rendimento econômico e talvez para
alguns setores não seja tão cômodo falar
da demanda então a reflexão que eu
queria deixar hoje aqui para vocês aqui
os objetivos da onu da agenda 2030 eles
devem começar por nós nós precisamos
primeiro tem uma visão crítica de tudo
que a gente escuta e de tudo que a gente
vê toda a história tem os dois lados
inserir e aumentar a inserção das
energias renováveis é importante eu não
tô falando aqui que não é é importante é
uma ação que realmente deve ser
continuada mas é suficiente não não é
suficiente a gente tem um longo caminho
para percorrer como o país e o que a
gente precisa de pessoas que têm a visão
crítica que pensa acerca daquilo que
isso
a pesquisa em então eu queria agradecer
a oportunidade de participar desse
evento é bom eu acredito que fomentar
esse tema não só o tema de meio ambiente
como todos os temas acerca da agenda
2030 é muito importante e eu estou à
disposição para qualquer dúvida que
vocês tiverem traz mesmo prazer
atendê-los obrigada